let me just ask you about family you
wrote that my family still jokes that
the reason I never had children on my
own was because I had already raised my
family they were right so this is
talking to you upbringing but in general
what was your
you know leading a giant company what
was the right place to find uh work-life
balance for you to have have time for
family yeah have time for away from work
and be successful so I had to learn that
and I might have said you know you're
the only one that can determine your own
work-life balance companies are innate
things I mean they will take everything
they can from you and it's not a bad
thing they just will as will bosses I
mean you give it they'll take it and
when people ask for you know I need roof
I'm like okay I had to come with terms
with the criminal was me
if I needed that balance I had to set
those boundaries and so when I comment
about a family because I am an extreme
awe of people with children who work it
is a extremely hard thing to do I watch
my siblings I love my nieces and nephews
and
who
you know a the emotional their pain is
your pain every minute of a day and then
you still have a job on top of it and so
when my mom had to go back to school and
had to work I was the one and so when
she couldn't go to the teacher meeting I
went to the teacher meeting when and so
in some ways and there's an age gap
between my brother and I and my other
two sisters and
so I'm still they they still call me
Mama Bear even I mean I I'm extremely
protective of all of them and it is as
if I had raised them and my mom did a
great job raising them I didn't I but I
was there and so
when it came time to have children and
my husband came from a family where his
father died and was raised by a single
mother very very similar endpoint
different reasons why he ended up you
know his father had not abandoned them
and
I don't want people to believe to do my
job you can have no children that is not
right I know other great women CEOs uh
Marilyn Houston who ran Lockheed Martin
extremely technical company Mary Barra
who runs General Motors Alan Coleman who
run Dupont these are all my friends to
this day
and
they've been fantastic mothers and
husbands of good parents right and so I
talk about it because it was a choice we
made and so you know we both felt look
we'd reached a point where for his
reasons what he had to do I'd already
felt that way and that we were
comfortable just being great aunts and
uncles and I'm a great aunt you know I
like to think that for my little guys
and all and they're older now but lots
of them and
and there's no doubt though the choices
we made Mark and I that that made it
easier for me to focus on work I mean
it's just it's just math you know when
you've got less people to have to take
care of and so I'm very considerate of
that and I think much of it informed
many of the policies I put into because
I had such great empathy for those who
then still had these other
responsibilities and I desperately
wanted them all to stay in the workforce
so I can remember and my siblings have
been more successful than I by the way I
mean to my mother's credit and my one
sister who uh you know went to
Northwestern has an MBA built some of
the most sophisticated systems uh she
spent her whole career at Accenture and
just recently retired as a chief
executive of all of Consulting but at
one point she took off time to be to
spend with her family and then went back
go back to work she's talking to me and
she's like I don't know if I should go
back to work you know maybe the life's
pay you know technology goes so fast
it's been a few years
I'm sitting there like what are you
talking about I'm like you know look at
her credentials they're far outstanding
I'm like
and I thought to myself like ding one of
those moments if my own sister feels
that way with all her credentials I'll
bet I went back to work the next day and
I said hey pull for me all the people
who've left for Parental reasons and or
whatever family reasons and didn't come
back and it began a program of return
ships and I can't tell you how many in
men and women was because they didn't
feel confident to come back they thought
technology passed by okay we said it's
three months you could stay one month
three months doesn't matter a lot of
people like one day they're like you're
right not that much happened well it
happened but I caught up I actually know
more than I think you know and and I so
with the long answer to your question
about I didn't but I am so empathetic
and I am in awe of what they are able to
do so uh and it made me then I think
more empathetic to the policies and the
like
um around that topic so you could keep
great people in the workforce